by the way three weeks into football
season and you already regret playing
fantasy football like you have a
defeated attitude that's what i heard
about yeah this is this is one of those
years where
nothing is going well uh you know i won
last week but this week i lost
and it's just like what am i doing yes
jd puppet what about you how are you
going by the way this is this is cutting
into my mountain time so you guys could
pick this up please
so jd it appears to me that you spend a
lot of time working
of course but also it's all fake
football
it's either madden pretend football or
this fantasy football league
are you in fact considering giving up
the league yes uh
without fantasy sports where would you
be i mean
i i don't see you giving this up i don't
know i might read a book or something i
don't know
well don't get crazy
so in other words your the fake football
league you're in is taking away
time from your fake football game and
maybe you want to just
devote yourself to the fake football
game and not split your intentions
is that it sure you know and also you
know i root for the bengals and they're
not having a great year so far
at the moment but isn't it great to be
in the competition
with your friends and well yeah sure but
like if you
suck the entire time and all you get is
like [ __ ] talk or rap before and
everyone else
jd you [ __ ] and that's the last time i'm
ever calling you jd your name is jamie
[ __ ]
the bengals is a tough team they're a
tough team to root for that you know
when's the last time they had a winning
season when is the last time they had a
winning season
uh it's been a little while so well you
know how i feel about it
you're a guy you live in new york how
many years you live in here
i i cannot root for the giants or the
jets i'm just listening
no how else would i waste my time right
thank you let me let me give you an
attitude adjustment
new york has been nothing but great to
you and this
uh cincinnati team reminds you of all
the [ __ ] in your life
getting to this point howard if if it
were that easy if i could switch
allegiance is that easy i would do it
but i i can't i'm
i'm looking at this it's in my blood jd
look at me
i want you to look i'm gonna choose a
team for you now i'm gonna decide
if you're a jet fan or a giant fan and
you're gonna i'll tell you what you know
what you look like
you look like a jet fan
i see these guys at the jet game you
look like
wow